Republican lawmakers fulfilled their
promise to take their work to the scene
of the crisis
in McAllen Texas the testimony from our
nation's border Chief as Republicans
search for answers and solutions the
White House accusing them of playing
partisan games with the hearing well
that is Rich considering Democrats are
playing their own
they were going
even spent our tax money on travel to
get there and then suddenly a political
flip they all canceled on that border
hearing
a republican spokesperson tells us those
members had booked the travel and even
called a witness before backing out
here's what they missed
g4ts
does
does DHS have operational control of our
entire border
no sir
so what is it exactly that the DHS
secretary Alejandro mayorkas has been
saying well not that truth here he is
last year
will you testify under oath right now do
we have operational control yes or no
yes we do and we have operational
control of the borders yes we do and it
was bad back then it's historically raw
and dangerous now so you know it's not
under control
in Focus art Del Cueto National border
patrol Council vice president first
Jackie Heinrich live at the White House
for us Jackie hey Harris yeah as you
mentioned Democrats were supposed to
attend this field Hearing in McAllen
Texas but they pulled out at the very
last second while the White House
slammed this event as a charade a
spokesperson wrote instead of playing
partisan games at the border extreme
Mega House Republicans should answer why
they're proposing to cut border security
funding by up to 20 percent denying
critical resources to the very Law
Enforcement Officers they claim to
defend but those who attended said this
was hugely consequential
it was groundbreaking for the first time
in two years we had an Administration
official admit to Congress that what we
all know that the border is not secure
that we don't have operational control
the border patrol Chief told lawmakers
his agents need help from Washington and
that a lack of deterrence has encouraged
many migrants to cross illegally he also
argued the decision to remove border
wall infrastructure was about politics
and not National Security
yeah
I do not believe in a wall from sea to
shine and sea but I do believe in
infrastructure and barrier systems in
concentrated areas especially urban
areas we tore down perfectly good
infrastructure systems in some areas
that we should have just left alone Del
Rio was a perfect example of that
Department of Homeland Security defended
itself after this hearing saying that it
showed the vital work that border patrol
agents are doing to enforce laws and
combat cartels and also said Chief
Ortiz's comments highlight the impact
that investments in things like
technology have made in this uh securing
the Border despite the system being
broken and dismantled when they
inherited it Harris Jackie thank you
very much art Del Cueto National border
patrol Council vice president in Focus
now art first of all look it turned
political pretty quickly when the
Democrats didn't show up but you can't
squel the truth I mean we are hearing
from the top border patrol agent and
what are you learning
well you know look it's it's been
political for quite some time but you
can't help it and that's because you
have two political parties one that
cares about securing our nation's border
and the other one that continues to
ignore that the problem exists so by
them not showing up that's another slap
in the face to everyone out here that's
putting their lives on the line and it's
really frankly a slap in the face to the
American public the problem is there the
problem exists and people need to know
the truth the only ones that are gaining
from this it's the drug cartels and you
know what the drug cartels don't care
what side of the aisle anyone's standing
on they just care about making money and
harming American lives well let me ask
you this
um when the top border patrol agent
suddenly goes on the record on Capitol
Hill with what you know to be true with
what we all know to be true for those of
us who've been down there and covered it
um what how does that change the game
because you have somebody in my orcas
who I know and you know that I know from
talking to people on the ground who have
told me that when the Haitians thousands
of them were under the bridge and Eagle
Pass my orcas the Secretary of DHS
called and said is that real or is that
a fake picture I mean not only did he
not want to take responsibility control
of that situation he wanted to pretend
like it was Make-Believe
no and and they also like to focus on
certain areas or what they want to do
Harris while those 16 000 Haitians that
you were talking about underneath the
bridge were happening there was over
twenty thousand gotaways in Tucson
sector but nobody was talking about
those individuals and that's where the
problem is I'm glad that Chief Ortiz
came up and said what was going on and
you know he was questioned and he was
truthful with his answers but you know
what it shouldn't take you to be in
front of Congress like that to to be
honest and to be able to say what's
happening you have individuals within
the national border patrol Council that
have been telling the truth they've been
talking about it for a long time we
don't need to be in front of Congress or
take an oath or you know say hey we
promise to tell the truth we just tell
the truth because it's the right thing
to do and you need to do it at all times
you can't wait till you know something
like this happens to all of us and they
say okay we don't have operational
control or to turn around and say hey
the meaning of operational control for
some people may be different than to
others no there is no difference
operational control is operational
control and when you're seeing the
number of illegals entering the country
record numbers every single year when
you're seeing the drugs coming into a
country or record numbers fentanyl
heroin and methamphetamines when you're
seeing the amount of gotaways go up each
and every single month and the only
thing that's growing down is the amount
of prosecutions or the amount of people
that are getting sent back to their
country that's a problem they've lost
operational control a long time ago well
look we're taking a view right now of
some of the godaways some of those
people who go around the checkpoints and
even go around where the sensors and the
cameras are because we've done
everything we can On the Border even
between the checkpoints to try to see
people but we can't catch everybody now
Customs and Border Protection is
tracking the so-called gotaways some
shocking numbers are popping though and
they're coming out of that hearing let's
watch
385 000 got away so far this fiscal year
how much more do you think got away you
know that you don't know about in my
estimation based upon the situation
awareness that I have probably be
between 10 and 20 sir more yes
wow that's a huge number we just heard
that's just in the first quarter of this
fiscal year that's on Pace to far exceed
the 600 000 in the entire
2022 fiscal year and nearly 400 000 the
year before that brings us to about 1.4
million godaways those people who are
here we don't exactly know who they are
or what they've done entering our
country since the start of fiscal 2021
this is ground shaking we are we're
failing in Epic ways here art
it's frightening it's horrifying and the
response from the agency is they know
the areas that are being affected by
godaways but instead of focusing more on
that area what they've done is now
they're sending agents to areas so they
can process faster when you hear them
say we need more agents they need more
so they can put them again in areas so
they can process faster and once again
those that are processing faster all
they're doing is releasing more and more
individuals into the United States
so when the White House accuses those
those who are doing the daily job
because that's really what they're doing
when they when they call a hearing at
the border a stunt what they're saying
is this is so unimportant nobody should
be there I guess that's why we haven't
seen them the White House and other
Democrats but when they say that how
does that reflect on the morale of the
people who have to do their jobs how
does it impact it
the morale is is already as low as it
can be you have agents out there that
are continuously getting assaulted you
have agents that are out there putting
in long hours when they're out there in
the field at night during the day at all
times and they do not feel like they
have the backing of the agency and they
don't feel like they have the backing of
the individuals at the White House and
you can tell because every time that
something happens that they can distort
to make the agents be the villain they
jump at it they jump at press
conferences and everything else but when
agents are getting attacked when agents
are getting assaulted they don't have
any press conferences for that they
don't justify you know hey the agent's
actions they're always justifying the
criminals actions well look I I just saw
a section of this video that catches my
eye every time it's when they're jumping
over and crawling through the turnstiles
if people want to get into this country
the legal way and they go to a
checkpoint there's a line to stand in
and there's a way to behave to get in
look at this these are not people who
necessarily have the intention of doing
it the right way they were just told get
there bum rush the border and they
thought they'd get in well you mentioned
him that top border Chief Raul Ortiz and
here's some of the numbers that he
shared uh yesterday at that hearing so
far in fiscal year 2023 border patrol
alone has apprehended more than 900
000 illegal immigrants from nearly 150
countries
so they're catching the people like some
of the ones we just saw there not
everybody wants to get in this way but
if you're bum Russian and you're
climbing and you're doing all that you
know that's not how the line works so
you've got nine hundred thousand compare
that to the same period in 2020 a
hundred and sixty thousand those are
just border patrol numbers total
encounters more than 1.2 million just
three years ago that number was only 280
000. so our when we say total encounters
we know that there in some places
National Guard I saw them in Eagle Pass
along the grand along the Rio Grande
because you guys are outnumbered I mean
in some cases at Sheriff's departments
in Texas and in Arizona I mean it's all
hands on deck and they're still
outnumbering us
right and the numbers are going up and
they've continued to go up from day one
is because this Administration they
created that magnet they let them know
hey if you come across if you ask for
Asylum you're going to get some
documentation you're going to be
released and you won't get sent back to
the country but look at it this way this
is the even more scary part when you're
seeing the amount of gotaways go up how
horrific and how terrifying could their
background their criminal background be
that they went that extra step not to be
detected not to be apprehended they
don't even qualify for just saying
simply Asylum and getting released
that's how horrific it is what are their
intentions where are they from what are
their criminal backgrounds and what are
they going to do to our country for many
many future Generations wow great
questions and really frightening ones
and you mentioned all the assaults as
they try to fight law enforcement when
they get here to try to get away and
stay here
it's getting harder and more dangerous
thank you for your service and for being
in Focus art Del Cueto
thank you hey everyone I'm Emily
compagno catch me and my co-host Harris
Faulkner and Kaylee mcineny on
outnumbered every weekday at 12 p.m
Eastern or sets your DVR also don't
forget to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page for daily highlights